if there's one thing that tesla has yet
to accomplish in their dream of making
electric cars and well their own brand
the standard for everyone who considers
owning a vehicle it is their prices and
although the model 3 from a couple of
years ago finally brought the car from
the stratosphere into the actually
available for more people realm at 35
000 for anyone who's not a middle class
american that is still pretty
substantial but just because he hasn't
done it yet don't think that our boy
elon doesn't have a plan for everything
and since his dream especially rests on
widespread electric car usage you can be
sure that tesla is just getting started
and we might know the biggest strategy
yet today we're discussing tesla's plans
to unveil a revolutionary new car one
that has been referred to as the model
2. although the exact details are a
little fuzzy we have plenty of stuff to
go on to see what exactly those guys
over at tesla are up to so to learn more
about this alleged model what it'll be
like how they'll design it and most
importantly what it means for tesla as
well as electric cars in general keep
watching this video
1. the name now before all of you get
confused with the naming scheme with the
new car being model 2 while the model 3
has been out for nearly 4 years now
let's clear up one thing first the model
2 is not the official name in fact it's
the working title or code name that
tesla employees use when referring to
the project now it very well might be
what the company ends up calling the car
when it gets released but until then we
can't really be sure after all with the
model s model 3 written as three dashes
like an e and model x all forming a very
clear image in our heads we should be
prepared for anything and everything
when it comes to elon naming stuff two
what is it now here's what we know about
all this tesla has for quite some time
wanted to release a small form factor
low-cost vehicle that'll be their proper
entry into the low-cost market because
the simple fact is although there are
profits to be made at the high end and
your brand reputation does depend on
your supercars and high luxury suvs the
actual cars that sell are the corollas
and ford focuses of the world and that's
exactly what the company intends this
model to be for them an affordable easy
to drive car that anyone from your
grandma to your young cousin can drive
3. how far it's in development another
thing to note is that although this
might come as a surprise to those of you
who have stand tesla for their high
speed and futuristic designs the
original goal of the company has always
been to develop affordable middle and
lower grade vehicles and so in one way
this is tesla coming to form as elon
intended it to although that may make
you think that the car is just ready to
come out well not just yet instead it is
still very much in development but just
how far is the point that varies from
person to person some people say that
the car has already been designed and
only the production aspect is left to
design and manage while others claim
that it's just a general goal with
nothing concrete underneath now the
reality of the situation is still
comparatively smudged as tesla is known
for being secretive about such details
to avoid competition but i'm pretty sure
as are many experts that the car is
somewhere in the late development cycle
with a lot left to finalize but the
general outline and underlying functions
are well established
4. where will it be made now this might
seem like an unimportant thing to
mention regarding a car but in the model
2's case it's actually rather important
you see instead of manufacturing the
cars in the states of the factories they
already own where stuff for the model s
3 and x are made along with the upcoming
cyber truck and roadster 2 tesla seems
to have very specific and separate plans
for the model 2 namely china it is a
well-known fact that mass manufacturing
is nowhere easier than in china and just
like apple google and the rest of the
big bunch tesla seems to have taken a
liking to the country as well because
they've acquired an entire plant in
shanghai by the name of gigafactory
shanghai just to manufacture the model 2
and that makes sense in a bunch of
different ways a it'll make the cost a
lot less compared to if they sold it as
is
and b china is kind of the world's smart
car center and with chinese
manufacturing their goals of making a
steady supply of cheap quality electric
vehicles might be a possibility 5. what
is the timeline now that we know what it
is and how they plan to make it let's
focus on the details that the company
and elon have revealed the story begins
last year when tesla announced that they
had plans to establish a new r d center
in china to develop and later
manufacture a chinese-style electric car
quite soon designs began to be drafted
and submitted until summer last year
after which the company even started
hiring for the program and all along we
got several mock-ups and sketches as to
what the car may look like even more
recently there have been several media
reports coming out of china that claim
the production of the model 2 could
start very soon however confirmation is
still lacking and we don't think there's
too much merit in that one thing that
has been confirmed however is the price
and direction which as we revealed will
be lower mid-range both in cost and
design in a company-wide meeting held
recently the ceo revealed that tesla was
aiming to start production of the new 25
000 car in 2023 six what will power it
now one of the biggest factors as to how
the company will manufacture such
absurdly cheap cars is not just based
around china but another thing namely
the new 4680 cells will impact it too
unlike older battery packs which use
strips of metal to connect an array of
cells the company seeks to remove the
multiple pieces of conductor that
connect a cell to others by a far more
efficient material and this battery is a
direct result of that along with that we
have a larger physical size specialized
for recharging at an entirely new
factory dedicated to manufacturing just
batteries as a result we get a promised
increase in charging times and add to
that 16 in range and five to six times
increase in power and energy so you can
see why the company is so eager to put
these into their hail mary car seven
what it'll look like now we understand
that the company is still deeply
secretive about the details of this car
fans however have had some luck in the
visual department specifically in the
form of an official sketch that
allegedly is of the upcoming car as the
image reveals the futuristic design is
very reminiscent of the model 3 the
company's other small volume and cost
vehicle leading many to believe that
this might become an entire line of
vehicles in time all in all it'll be a
small hatchback probably around the size
of a ford focus with tesla's usual
futuristic flare 8. what the interior
will look like the interior of most cars
might not be the most important thing
for many people after all aren't all
cheap car interiors basically the same
well as it turns out the interior is the
single biggest piece of news out there
so what astounding new feature will be
seen in this car of dreams well as it
turns out it's the lack of features that
will determine the wow factor of the car
because according to elon himself in the
aforementioned conference the car will
feature as an effort from tesla towards
achieving a deployable full self-driving
system musk even asked tesla employees
do we want to have this car come with a
steering wheel and pedals and if you
look back into the company history
there's definitely precedent for that as
early as 2019 tesla has revealed their
plans for self-driving fleets and even
unveiled an image of a vehicle without a
steering wheel and pedals and went on to
say that they wanted to make it within
two years and with the version 10.1 of
tesla's autopilot system on the way it's
not a stretch to say that the first
instance of a completely autonomous car
might be the model 2 so the future nerds
can hold on to that 9. when will it come
out
last but not least the release date well
according to sources from the tesla
company meeting the company plans to
start production on a 25 000 car by 2023
and by all accounts this is what the
model 2 will be and so if everything
goes according to plan you can expect to
see them on the road by 2024 and that my
friends covers all that we know about
the model 2. sure there are a lot of
ambiguities but this should give you
some idea of this car of the future with
that it's time to wrap up thank you so
much for watching leave a like if you
enjoyed the video and i'll see you next
time